let's get reaction now from the
president and his team to the Cohen
testimony we start there at least chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
traveling with the president here in
Vietnam to cover the summit leads off
with a pretty minimal response so far
good morning John good morning to you
Brad so far there has been no response
to Cohen's testimony by President Trump
other than a tweet that he sent out
which preceded Cohen's testimony in
which he said that Cohen had done bad
things unrelated to Trump one of the
president's outside attorneys though Jay
Sekulow did respond to a portion of
Cohen's testimony saying quote today's
testimony by Michael Cohen that
attorneys for the president edited or
changed his statement to Congress to
alter the duration of the Trump Tower
Moscow negotiations he's completely
false no question though Cohen's
testimony on Capitol Hill today left the
president fighting to keep his summit
with Kim jong-un in the news spotlight
the Michael Cohen testimony barged in on
president Trump's second meeting with
Kim jong-un the president refusing to
answer questions about his former
attorney
but we did get some insight into the
president's thinking from South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham who spoke with
him before Cohen's testimony it did
bother him that there's going to be a
split screen between Michael Cohen and
then meeting with a Kim jong-nam and I
said well that's just the world in which
you live in his meeting and social
dinner with Kim president Trump playing
his cards close to his vest predicting
success president Trump and Kim jong-un
have a signing ceremony scheduled for
this afternoon
the president is under pressure from
both sides of the political aisle to
make progress on Kim's promise at last
June's first summit to dismantle his
nuclear program my bigger worry is
probably that North Korea will give too
little or nothing because what we saw
last year is really no commitment of any
substance it is unclear what the
President and Kim will sign and the
substance of a deal could shift during
today's meetings ideas that have been
kicked around our opening liaison
offices in the United States and North
Korea to facilitate ongoing dialogue
closing down the young beyond nuclear
facility an agreement to finally end the
Korean War and some modification of
sanctions President Trump has been
trying to sell Kim on the economic
benefits he could reap if he gives up
his weapons of mass destruction ends
North Korea's isolation and joins the
global economy and as I've said many
times
I think that your country has tremendous
economic potential unbelievable
unlimited and I look forward to watching
it happen and helping it to happen North
Korea experts tell Fox News it is
unlikely Kim would give up his nuclear
program all at once there is still deep
distrust of the United States in North
Korea one of the president's goals this
week and in his one-on-one meeting last
night to build trust between the two
countries we will find out more about
how the summit went and what the two
leaders agreed to when President Trump
holds a press conference this afternoon
it's also a safe bet that he will be
asked about the Kohen testimony as well
Brett will cover all of that right here
John thank you